schools are basically glorified vampires
that eat human flesh that's why this
shit's stupidly popular on tumblr
hey yo buddy oh wow I'm your best friend
even though I'm not actually irrelevant
to the end go ahead and that girl
you mean the age of teenager who looks
like she has daddy issues I know that
one do you want to come over for dinner
[ __ ] yeah she wants to have me for
dinner oh god she's having me for dinner
tough luck hey one of the strong schools
out there that date could have gone
better
Oh your organs were ruptured but luckily
there was a random lady they shoes
although organs intact so we just with
the menu no questions asked
that sounds stupidly illegal and
irresponsible I know I'm gonna eat that
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
oh it's you eat this human yet it
nobody's give the [ __ ] Gramps he won't
stop crying
can you help bring coffee wow this is
great see this isn't so bad
there he goes again come on we need to
get you a mask from anime Skrillex hi
I'm Adam a Skrillex and I'm not gonna
actually do anything in the show
do me 3 what about him I'm fabulous and
a potential pedophile would you like to
come back with me for some candy now
Kenickie do you remember what mama told
you to say that strange men who are
potential pedophiles offer you candy yes
you lied to me she was just a joke here
you can clean up at my place I don't see
any harm in that
[Music]
maniacal sadistic [ __ ] who looks like he
raped babies for a living on the
righteous white night partner who for
some reason doesn't care about anything
he does oh look at a fenceless little
girl would you like some candy don't
fall for it it's a trap the hell is it
kind of keep what I need him Oh what the
[ __ ] I literally have no idea what the
[ __ ] you're talking about
Shh it's okay have a Snickers serves you
right you sadistic wait a minute oh and
he was married no I'm looking for my
sister Nisa he's your brother
well you two do look very alike honey
he's been kidnapped oh I'm sure he's
doing fine all right I guess we can get
him why are you doing this to me Jason
pictures I'm a watching copyright
infringement huh you look pathetic says
the person who got killed by some
falling pipe sucking hex mode on what
why is your hair turned white cuz it
makes me look more badass
so why of your nails turned black cos it
makes me look fat oh the most dangerous
good of all time the one-eyed ow whoa
kaneki you look different I am NOT
kaneki anymore I am con hedgy [ __ ] you I
have white hair so are you coming back
with us thanks but I'm enjoying the
people who kidnapped and tortured me
what that makes no sense probably does
in the Hmong I'll always remember you're
physically deformed faces you were
trying to slaughter children hey hon is
what brings you to this grave he's my
dad he's your what we're so desperate
for new recruits we even hide a small
boy why are you girls I don't know will
you be my daddy sure just make sure to
behave yourself
there he goes manically killing things
again they grow so fast so what now we
listened to the out of nowhere awesome
soundtrack
does any of what happened matter anyway
probably does in the manga Oh for [ __ ]
sake he's back in town
he's what oh [ __ ] you
fancy meeting you here again I was
thinking about your dad who I respected
a lot my dad was a psychopath
yeah well he's dead now so we're
supposed to like him Oh God talking
about my dead father makes me so horny
wait a minute
guys guess who I'm gonna press it on
guys like guys oh whatever just got the
ball I have to find kaneki ready go
Oh God you look like Vash the Stampede
and Alexander Aronson at a game each and
baby and you look like Luigi started
taking steroids
[Music]
I'm dying Oh buddy Oh pal no you were
you were why who are you again I was
your best friend you're my best friend
don't worry pal I'll get you to the
place you belong here we go
we should be getting there any second
walking laser is so much pain Masseria I
hope to god tokens doing better than me
and Jamaica retain their title 56.8 five
at the world record has been taken apart
hey guys gig okay hope you enjoyed the
latest episode of anime in minutes if
you liked see the previous episode which
was sort out online or any feature
episodes and just click on the links
here and I'd like to give a huge thank
to my voice actors for doing a great job
in making this episode what it was also
know I said in the previous episode that
I was aiming for a monthly schedule but
in case you missed it it's looking more
like a six-week schedule per episode at
the moment considering how much work it
takes unless I can find someone to help
me lessen the load in future anyway
that's it for me and not many updates
for me today so I've been gigging and
I'll see you all next time